[Music]
hey youtubers its charlie
huge news for legend of korra tonight so
they're airing all four final episodes
tonight
Janet Varney made the announcement on
tumblr they said that if they could get
10,000 reblogs they would air the final
two episodes a week early on Nick comm
at midnight tonight this video will be a
review of episodes 11 and 12 and then
I'll do a separate review for episodes
13 and 14 be sure to subscribe to get it
since there's so much awesome core to
get through tonight let's do our
favorite moments real quick and then
I'll do my review first off
high-five yourself if you guessed dark
avatar Luna Locke explained that once
harmonic convergence started he would
fuse with vaatu and because they would
be in perfect alignment they would be a
much more powerful avatar than raava and
Korra would be this doesn't explain how
he can be the avatar without having all
four elements but I think that the show
neurs just want to imply that vaatu
would give him that ability just like
raava kind of held all four elements for
whan but that doesn't confirm whether or
not there will actually be a dark avatar
we'll find out in those last two
episodes though we got to see harmonic
convergence and the visual effect as
well as the soundtrack during a lot of
these scenes were amazing watching that
wave of dark energy just enveloped the
entire planet if you're confused about
what that means is is when harmonic
convergence happens it basically
amplifies spiritual energy so any
spirits walking around now are ten times
more powerful it doesn't explain whether
all benders become more powerful but
spirits definitely become more powerful
that's why vaatu is able to break out of
his tree prison that classic fire
ferrets scene at the end was also
amazing obviously Bolin kind of had his
moment at the beginning of the episode
in the arena Olin and Michael were
basically running a block on unlock
while Korra was trying to close the
portal he didn't do it in time but it
was still amazing scene classic fire
ferrets are ferrets right or die
next up my two favorite characters in
these two episodes were one Bolin or
should I say nuktuk sky warrior and -
Bumi with his flute in the last couple
of episodes Bolin's character has kind
of gotten pushed to the side while korra
deals with her spiritual misalignment or
tries to get realigned with raava so it
was awesome to watch him get his big
hero moment in the arena especially when
the action on-screen started to mirror
the action in the arena I actually
thought that Bolin and Asami we're gonna
hook up in that first episode but it
turns out Masami is still a thing but
I'll talk about that
during my funniest moments so Bhoomi was
my favorite character from harmonic
convergence not only did he inception
team Korra with the aerial assault idea
he also took out the entire southern
encampment guarding the portal obviously
it was a big funny scene too but we
learned that you can pacify spirits with
music so obviously not all spirits
because it led to that big destruction
scene but I think that his flute is
gonna come in handy later or it's going
to inform some of the characters
strategy raise your hand if you thought
the soundtrack during that whole Bhoomi
destruction scene when he climbed in the
mech was amazing the sound just picked
up and was perfect for that scene it was
hilarious and the action was amazing as
a side note I'll also probably be doing
a giveaway for the chorus soundtrack
whenever they released the book to
soundtrack as for my funniest scenes in
the episodes though even though Bumi
kind of brought most of the comedy the
Masami versus McCory especially in that
first episode was amazing right below in
the comments how many different
expressions do you think went across
Makos face when he tried to deal with
korra and asami it must have been at
least 20 20 expressions of awkward in
under 30 seconds it was hilarious or
mock oh he brought this on himself
though but the big questions we have
after this episode and before the finale
are one will unlock fuse with vaatu and
how a course stop them if they do become
the dark avatar because remember they're
supposed to be more powerful than she
and raava together - how will they save
Jinora we didn't see Jinora in this
episode but she's still in the spirit
world 3 will the twins betray unlock and
help team Korra and for what will Korra
do to pacify all the dark spirits
roaming around in the human realm even
if she does defeat unalaq and vaatu and
closes the spirit portals that won't
make the spirits go away so she'll still
have to pacify all of them and get them
to go back through the spirit portal
into the spirit world but what did I
think of the episode overall I give it a
solid b-plus
it was great I really loved the way it
took side characters or at least main
characters that hadn't been serviced and
really gave them big moments it paid off
a lot of moments for people like Bolin
and Bumi that had kind of been pushed to
the side for a long time the action was
great the soundtrack was great it's
still not as good as beginnings
beginnings are still my all-time
favorite Korra episode right now but it
went a long way to answering some of our
biggest questions like the dark avatar
question even though there are a bunch
of questions that still remain
unanswered we'll find out after the
finale because it literally the last two
episodes will be airing at midnight
tonight
on me calm that's Eastern Time I'll be
doing a video for that be sure to
subscribe to get it I'll post it right
after the episode airs so it'll be late
tonight but let me know what your
favorite moments were and if there was
anything that you thought was really
important that I didn't mention in the
video it was an hour of Korra so there's
a lot of stuff that went on be sure to
write it in the comments and we'll
discuss if I write now click here to get
my review of the finale I'll add the
annotation as soon as I post the video
in a couple hours and click here to
learn all about my Doctor Who 50th
anniversary giveaway I'm giving away a
DVD so you have some chance to win some
free stuff high fives
I'll see you guys later tonight
[Music]